I has a secret diner in there and this
is what he saw
we'll grab some lunch we just you just
grab a seat okay I love that you do
dripping such a good idea the dripping
you know your roast and then the
dripping you'd have throughout the week
spread on the bread
cheap cheerful slightly nostalgic really
nice and look how happy you know
customer sounds really good
all right this is ox tongue corned beef
nowhere near seasoned they're not very
bland
that's quite disappointing actually it's
such a shame because the the diner shut
up
Wow dripping except and then bang ah
[ __ ] when you've got the balls to put
corned beef and opsin on a plate that's
simply it has to be seasoned perfectly
I've actually changed our name because
we've had the comment card that night it
was essentially a lack of seasoning uh
yeah you know thanks a lot
I really wasn't expecting that I know
our purple I'm probably out to pay for
I'd like to pay for it sure you maybe
was no I'd like to pay for really they
won't let us pay no charge nice gesture
gives me no reason to complain about it
I love the way he was so patient and so
polite really polite on several occasion
that we've seen some really succinct
very focused ability in the kitchen that
very well steals food and then you get
things like these is full of chips you
know perhaps not even a place of their
claims we call ourselves gastro pubs
that serve our chips enough useless hmm
burnt chips it's a simple stupid mistake
that shouldn't really happen ever chef
chef chef chef around well I want to
talk to you about something wonderful
about that look at that would you eat
that would you read that no so why
should I eat it no I want to talk to
chef
yeah I'd love to see alright hi there
brilliant well they've gone out but I
wanted to teach
but I just wonder why you love that chef
to get out when it was burnt sounds like
you're trying to do quite a lot up that
positions well you better get back up
there but thanks for coming down I
thought you were going to blow a gasket
to be honest I could cry I could cry a
chip goes out like it's on the back of
an ass end of a takeaway van
there's flashes of brilliance in there
and it works in such a magical way and
that you bust your balls fresh bread
we're in Peaks cooking school yeah slow
down and focus on what you've got this
chips will burn the shunt of in burn
they should have been absolutely fine
they should have been fantastic the guy
should have been picking them out of the
bowl saying my god these are [ __ ]
amazing chips seen a lot of problems
that we do need to solve but we've also
seen a lot of strengths that we know we
have got so as long as we bring
everything together tiny hope I think we
can improve and we can make things
better than the ever happened